yeah yeah we started yet you'll know
what we start and also kind of just say
this though - right I can't believe we
haven't had you on earlier that's my bad
I can't believe it's not butter yeah you
know how your name came up though Rosie
did it last week he did yeah I was one
of my best friend
I know Rosie did it and he's like have
you had I don't know I never even asked
him it's okay but I'm honored honored to
be here it's a real honor thank you
always an honor to do anything with the
kid yeah we haven't started yet no go
five four three
wait stop before you know before it keep
it rolling but um
don't say anything till I bring it up
say your name five four three two one
yeah
hello uh-huh that's right no no no I
keep I do it the way I want to do it
okay hello what's up uh-huh well welcome
my name is maja Billie and welcome to
the celebration celebration okay stop
yep stop welcome to episode number 302
something in the hundreds upping the
hundreds welcome to this one this is a
celebratory uh event tonight evening
we've got me I am great
I'm wonderful I you know I look in the
mirror I go that's the way it is and
that's okay really that is the way it is
and that's the way it's gonna be okay
not don't say anything yeah
we've got my beautiful little lotus
flower here from the Philippine Islands
lotus flower or lotus l'eau de l'eau de
flag
yeah nonexistent we beautiful though
she's great she's got milky skin
she's got wet hands right and she's
moist but her brain is the most
important thing she's very smart
she probably she's a bright girl is a
bright girl and she has an education and
it's un-fuckin'-believable she went to
college and our minds what we Mel dude
it's like [ __ ] simple but great I
learned we got right here we got um just
I you know I keep calling you flat no
Harlan not yet okay we got right here we
got uh the brownness face you from this
side of Tiki island thank you so much
yeah yeah Jon Jon what's your name Joe
Gilbert Oh Gilbert Melendez
Glenda's yet whatever and then we've got
right here [ __ ] serial killer 101 right
here dude not only does it kill he skins
the [ __ ] dick skin off and [ __ ]
wear it makes a helmet Oh puts it on his
own thing and we got a stuff stupid
stupid stupid stupid stupid stupid
stupid stupid stupid stupid cousin right
here welcome to the show we have a very
[ __ ] great gasps man I can't even
believe we this guy is it has a
doctorate in metaphysics yep um he he
makes dream catchers out of dilithium
crystals and adamantine steel Wow two
elements that you can't really find on
this planet nope right he is uh written
poetry right a couple of books right
yeah a couple of books both of them are
about physiology and the mind and the
third one's about the history of before
pre-industrial revolution very only in
Vermont though specific specific Vermont
this guy right here man makes maple
sitter syrup out of them just pine trees
oh he can get he invented a machine they
make [ __ ] maple syrup out of pine
trees right he's a doctor doctorate
Humphrey me given Stevens is he here
three hello excuse me doctor thank you
talk about your books okay the first one
I published in 1983 yes and many years
doing research up and Berkley yes and
some of the findings were just you know
just unbelievable they were
groundbreaking and the book inspired
many other people to come behind me and
continue the research I step back yeah
yeah and we opened a wing at Berkeley
what's a wing called barbecue and the
research is ongoing so the book was a
real hit but called again I forgot I
didn't I said on Wikipedia oh you see
you said it earlier yeah my findings on
earth yeah right and the second one was
second one was in terms why are they I
think they're longer than an inch right
and my research shows that the art yeah
yeah unbelievable that's a great book do
you like insects I do
I like praying mantises the most because
when you take them hostage they pray you
know the other insects just sit there
and look like [ __ ] praying mantis
Oh pray before you stomp alright I'll
let them go cuz they pray so do you
think they're spiritual creatures well
yeah and there's power and prayer as you
know so that summer I do that yes I'll
let them go now on that yeah how's the
family uh which one
oh you several that's right you were
married a couple of times yeah Habashi
safor Nia Oh your first wife a phony oh
my god yeah she never did phone me so I
lost you did yeah and yeah unbelievable
oh yeah I haven't seen her in a while
yeah uh no do you miss her
sometimes yeah I at night when I'm
laying there with you know boxes of
thumbtacks and corkboards
I miss her fingers yeah she was a pygmy
right Wow